Speaker 1: Trump is again asking Putin to
help him find dirt on people this time.
Hunter Biden will talk about that a little
bit later in the show, but it doesn't seem
Merrick Garland wants to do anything.
We've got these Manhattan investigators who
resigned, including Mark Pomerantz, saying
we had good evidence that Trump committed
crimes.
If we tried some of these cases, we would
likely win.
But it doesn't seem any charges are coming
there, and multiple prosecutors have resigned
as a result.
A federal judge recently said, and we talked
about it earlier this week.
It's pretty apparent that Donald Trump committed
felonies.
And yet what?
Nothing.
The Department of Justice seems to be completely
feckless, and you have to understand that
this is bigger than just Merrick Garland in
general, no one.
The checks and balances that we have our checks
and balances.
But they never accounted for someone like
Trump.
They just didn't.
And we talked about this during the Trump
era, and the federal bureaucracy in general
has never really held presidents accountable
in any serious way.
So about 10 different things have to happen,
including Democrats earning more votes, the
DOJ taking this seriously.
And unfortunately, it sort of seems like many
Democrats are more willing to allow the possibility
of democracy dying than to take the gloves
off and saying, Hey, you know what?
We do have to do some unprecedented things,
but that's because we've already had unprecedented
circumstances.
The Trump presidency was already unprecedented,
and when that's the case, you might have to
take unprecedented action.
Very scary times ahead.
And it is not hyperbolic to say that democracy
is in peril as yet another example of this.
Let's talk about yet another request from
Donald Trump to Vladimir Putin.
So Trump is again asking Putin to help him
find dirt.
You might remember that Donald Trump previously
said Russia.
If you're listening, you will be rewarded
for hacking Hillary's emails and the DNC.
And then within hours, that's exactly what
Russia did.
We are in the middle right now globally of
a Russian invasion of Ukraine, an invasion
of aggression and illegal invasion and invasion
that doesn't respect the sovereignty of the
Ukrainian people or of the Ukrainian borders.
That's what's going on.
And not only has Donald Trump praised Putin
as a genius and savvy and smart.
Early in the invasion, not only has Trump
used very soft language about Putin, like
saying recently that he's driven to put it
together in reference to the invasion of Ukraine.
Trump is now asking Putin, Can you give us
some dirt on Hunter Biden?
Dozens of articles about this, including this
article from Politico Trump calls on Putin
to release dirt on Hunter Biden.
It's the latest example of the former president
soliciting foreign governments to intervene
to damage his domestic political rivals.
Remember, he also withheld aid from Ukraine,
wanting Ukraine to announce an investigation
into the Biden family for the PR benefit.
He ultimately was sort of shamed into giving
Ukraine the military aid once that information
leaked or broke.
So Trump appears on Real America's Voice will
look at other pieces of this interview later
in the show.
And Trump says, You know, we're not going
to get the truth about Hunter from Ukraine,
but maybe Putin can give it to us.
Listen to this.
This is as crazy as it has been made out to
Speaker 2: be anything while I'm on your show.
As long as Putin now is not exactly a fan
of our country.
Let him explain where did because Chris Wallace
wouldn't let me ask the question, why, why
did the mayor of Moscow's wife?
Give the Bidens both of them three and a half
million dollars, and that's a lot of money.
She gave him three and a half million dollars,
so now I would think Putin would know the
answer to that.
I think he should release it.
I think we should know that answer.
Wow.
Now you won't get the answer from Ukraine,
but why are they giving somebody?
Who knows nothing about energy?
One hundred and eighty seven thousand dollars
a month, plus a $3 million upfront payment.
And I won't even talk about China because
they haven't gone into Taiwan yet.
That'll be next.
Speaker 1: I love the hosts nodding along
like they have any idea what Trump is talking
about.
Speaker 2: But why did the mayor of Moscow's
wife give the Biden family three and a half
million dollars?
Nobody was asked the question, and Chris Wallace,
who's a total lightweight, unlike his father,
who interviewed me for 60 Minutes, who was
actually a good piece.
Mike Wallace was great.
He wants to be Mike Wallace, but he doesn't
have the talent.
But why is it that the mayor of Moscow's wife
gave the Biden family three and a half minutes?
Speaker 1: Now, of course, he means for four
people who are confused.
Why is Trump talking about a female horse?
He's saying the mayor, not the mayor.
OK, just just that.
That could be just the New York accent thing.
I know people in the audience will say, horses,
what is he talking about?
I know that we've lost our our capacity for
shock.
But the president of the United States is
trying to fight Russia because Russia is invading
Ukraine.
Fight through sanctions and fight through
training.
I'm talking about Joe Biden.
While a former president of the United States
in the middle of that fight is asking a Naito
adversary that is illegally invading another
country to help him politically.
That's what Donald Trump is doing.
And of course, this isn't the first time that
Trump has done it.
This is that famous time the the Russia, if
you're listening debacle Russia.
Speaker 2: If you're listening, I hope you're
able to find the 30000 emails that are missing.
I think you will probably be rewarded mightily
by our press.
Speaker 1: And hours later, that is exactly
what Russia is believed to have done.
The difference is that this time there may
be less of a payoff to Russia to releasing
so-called dirt if it exists on Hunter Biden,
whereas there was a significant payoff back
then because we know of Russia's preference
for Trump over Hillary Clinton, so he's doing
it again later in the show.
We'll look at some other moments from this
disturbing interview.
Let me know your thoughts.
Find me on Twitter at Packman.
The David Pakman Show is primarily funded
by our audience, people who listen to the
podcast.
Watch clips on YouTube, listen to the show
on the radio, maybe on your local radio station.
You can support our work by signing up at
Join Packman dot com and we do an extra show
every single day for our members.
You can also now gift memberships to others.
When you sign up, just check the box.
This is a gift membership.
If you want to give the gift to someone specific,
you can, if you leave it blank, will give
it to someone.
We've got a waiting list right now of two
hundred and twenty people who have requested
memberships and can't afford them, so that
is something that is available as well.
Join Packman dot com